it's crazy that people love to have uh
pets like that they love it
like to live in america and kill a tiger
like yeah
um
listen
they give you the false sense of
security that you're in control they're
smart they know what they're doing and
then oh he really wants me to slay down
with him and play with him oh really
oh really i'm gonna give him a [ __ ] let
me see how you like that
you really like me
those [ __ ] right in your bed no but
definitely i never had that but they
fought it
they might as well [ __ ] because they
thought they might as well [ __ ] how bad
is a tiger fart oh man
listen the house [ __ ] up all the
windows gotta be open you gotta firm
again you gotta call some [ __ ]
you know when they breathe smoke in the
house
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] happened mike
oh my god don't make sense
at my house
of course tiger farts are the worst
you have no idea you would think that
this is not real this is not coming out
of anything that breathes air
this didn't come out of something that
breathes air it's no [ __ ] way joe
[Music]